hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the 2019 FIBA
World Cup even though it just ended a
lot of we have already suggested it and
it's the game anyhow Arion vs elsa
farley we already mentioned that we're
probably gonna cover this game as Neil
had a promising position and it's very
interesting what came out of this game
now some of you may not know this but
Nicholson was included in a training
camp with well six of a very promising
young Indian grandmasters I don't know
if all of them were grandmasters I know
at least three were grandmasters I had a
training camp with Vladimir Kramnik
and well this is now even though Anita
was a very strong player it's very
interesting to see what training with a
legend like Vladimir Kramnik
yeah it improved in all of them so
without further ado let's check it out a
lot of you have requested it and it's a
it's a well pretty long theoretical
struggle in the opening so we're not
gonna dwell too long on that efore a5 as
the game is real opus night of three
Knight to c6 Bishop to b5 the reuleaux
pieces on the board a six more fees
defense push up to a four Knights to f6
now castles are with Bishop to e7 and
now rook to e1 b5 pushing the bishop
back Bishop to b3 in the now d6 with c3
making room for the bishop and c2 also
preparing the advancement of the pond
with the d3 or d4 we have castles by
black and now h3 and here black goes for
the Brer bear defense with Knights to be
a this Knight is now going over to d7
with d4 by White Knight B to d7 and now
Knight B to d2 the night is not going to
f1 and then either to III or g3
depending on what black plays Bishop the
b7 and now Bishop the c2 we've worked
late and night to f1 as planned
Bishop to f8 and this has been played so
many times that there are over 2000
games in the database from tournament
play with this exact same position so
this is nothing new to either of them
tonight the g3 with g6 now taking away
the f5 and h5 squares from White Knight
and also preparing Bishop
seven with a four by nickel and an out
Bishop to g7 Bishop to d3 now putting
pressure on b5 you want to play a
character son b5 and win a pawn
and here comes c6 just defending it you
can't well just defending it with the
shop to g5 now pinning the knight
developing the Bishop h6 Bishop back to
e3 so like I said all has been played
before Queen to c7 developing the Queen
connecting rooks and Queen to d2 now now
putting pressure on the h6 pawn black
has to deal with this we have king to h7
and now there have been a few moves that
have been played in position D captures
on e5 has been played rook to a2 has
been played rook to a3 has been played
Queen to c2 has been played as the King
now nicely occupies the h7 square but
here the move needle place is a new move
into position b4 which comes with the
idea of grabbing more space on the Queen
side which we'll see in the game and it
is already as I've moved 20 that we have
a completely new game which is not odd
as there's quite a lot of theory around
the reuleaux PES night the b6 now and
with D captures on e5 d capture sunny 5
and a 5 now pushing the knight further
back with 9b d7 and now C for preparing
to grab even more space with c5 if you
play c5 with this light square Bishop is
just a disgusting piece that's no way to
treat your bishop and also if you can't
capture and c4 then you get bunch of
characters you go after f7 after rogue
defense you're gonna go rook a c1 and
the White has a has an excellent
excellent position
so after this c4 movie a group a to d8
by Safari of course you want to put your
rook on an open D file that now the
White Queen also occupies Queen back to
a2 and here comes a move that will come
to hunt so Farley very soon he plays
King to g8 probably the will maybe to
get the King off of this diagonal but
also to add another defender to the f7
pawn but this will not work out the way
he planned Bishop the c2 by nickel and
now comes Queen to d6 going after to be
for pawn but
a brilliant move by Nikhil he plays
Bishop to b3 which comes with a question
do you want to grab the pawn on b4
the problem with capturing and b4 is c5
and now even though black can capture on
c5 white is threatening Bishop captures
on f7 so having your King there doesn't
really help but okay for example if you
defended rookie 7 now you get rook e to
b1 and how do you how do you save the
queen Bishop captures on f7 is the
threat this would open up discovery
against the black Queen you have to
waste another move move your king but
still the shop captures on f7 you have
to move the Queen Queen c3 now you get
Bishop captures on g6 even that King
captures Knight a5 and the position is
very enjoyable basically it plays itself
you can go look back to e8 if you don't
want to lose material Knight h4 check
King h7 and now even Queen to f7
threatening checkmate once you prevent
this rogue g8 you get Bishop captures on
h6 and it's well it's it's just over
black black has no more moves so after
Bishop to b3 we have Queen back to east
7 adding another defender here getting
the Queen away from the default as of
course you know that the rook is coming
to occupy the D file so rook a to d1 and
now black would really like to play c5
you want to play c5 and free your little
height square bishop but let's say you
play c5 again you're gonna have problems
defending the f7 pawn there it's just
too much problem for example B captures
the knight captures Bishop captures you
again get to the Queen away from the
defense of the f7 pawn now you play
capture some d5 open up an attack
against the f7 pawn and now after the
Queen goes back you have to defend it or
something you're either gonna for
example Queen to e7 you're either gonna
push b6 or you're gonna allow this
capture and get a passed pawn already on
a6 you can go Knight h4 threaten to
capture here as the F pawn is not only
attacked it's also pinned so a lot of
very nice ideas for white here so Safari
went looked the c8 and the now comes
Knight to h4 putting pressure on this g6
pawn and black no longer wants to
constantly keep an eye on this so Kings
to f8
the f1 is no longer pinned and now c5
and now if you look at this Bishop
that's just that's just a very ugly
Bishop and the other pieces are not
doing a such a great job either so far
that plays Knight to b8 and what what is
nice to be a doing the knight isn't
really going anywhere the night will
come back to d7 but if you want to at
least try and trade some rocks along the
D file you have to for the moment to put
it there and here
Neha plays a wonderful move rook to d6
and just just typhoon blacks position
completely caught a glimpse of not just
24 coverage with young Gustavson and
can't remember the other guys named
Lawrence Trent and Magnus Carson had a
phone call at the time they were
checking out this position and Carson
said that about this position that it's
it's like black is down a piece black is
so bad that he could well he as if he
was down a piece and he also shown
showed a very nice line for example roof
to c7 if you want to bring another
defender here then just Knight to f5
will win the Queen the Queen has nowhere
to go
the rook is covering all of the squares
so the Queen is trapped even if you
capture once you're gonna lose the Queen
and and you could pretend that you gave
it away for some material but still
rugby 7 Bishop c5 Black has no moves
whatsoever in this position so it's it's
very hard to play something like this
but ok after rugby 6 so far Lee decided
that he was not going to get his Queen
trap he played rook 8 d8 offering a rook
trade and also freeing some room for the
Queen
but Nihal went in for it just the same
with Knight g2f sorry night GTA 5
attacking the Queen we have a capture
once so a piece sacrifice but shouldn't
should not be a problem Queen to c7 the
c7 is now free for the Queen and now
Knight captures on g7
King captures and now of course you'll
see it Bishop captures on h6
beautiful beautiful moves King captures
and now
captures on f6 with check now the
problem is if you go to g7 just rook
captures on f7 would check wins the
Queen and you don't really have enough
compensation your pieces aren't really
doing all that much
so after King to g5 was played
nickel-plated rook the f5 check we have
King back to h6 and here and he'll just
played well a lot of moves are good here
but he played the absolute strongest
move Queen to d2 and it was in this
position that elder Safari resigned the
game as there is nothing more you can do
the queen is coming to h5 and you cannot
do anything to prevent it you might try
running waking to g7 but still you get
going to g4 check and slowly but surely
you are you are getting destroyed King
f8 the queen is coming to h5 you're
putting more and more pressure on the f7
square and there's really not not much
you can do here so it would be pointless
to continue yeah after this very nice
Queen to e2 move lter Safari resigned
the game and another excellent victory
for Nichols Irene who I think I don't
know if there's anyone in the World Cup
so far with three wins all in classical
so nickel bit
Jorge Cory in the previous round with
both wins with the white and black
pieces and now a victory against Delta
Safari so it seems that the the climate
Kramnik training camp is definitely
paying off and it's gonna be well if he
continues playing like this just
complete annihilation of his opponents
you know he could get a very very far in
the well into into the World Cup and
maybe who knows maybe even grab a seat
in the candidates tournament as I don't
think ever since Bobby Fischer played in
the nineteen
in the 1959 candidates tournament in
bled Belgrade and Zagreb I believe he
was 15 at the time so I don't know if or
or maybe 16 I don't know if anyone that
young played in the candidates
tournament ever since so it would be
very interesting but there's a long way
to go from there so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Oliveira optic and Marcel
Fernandez for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Vita
World Cup and of course checking up on
your wonderful suggestions so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend